so these are two of the best
starting pitchers that haven't qualified
you know for postseason honors and that
type of thing so you won't see police
act and keller on any of the
leaderboards but these are two of the
very very top pitchers i think in the
american league right now it should be a
very good matchup tonight swung out and
missed police act strikes him out with
the slider
and there's one down here in the first
week bro what a play by police how about
that leaping in the air to snare one and
take it away for out number one to get
over there and at least make an attempt
and to
concentrate enough to catch that ball a
lot of guys are to let go go and let the
middle enfield was taken not that bubba
starling and he's down on strikes second
k for police two down runner goes
pitches low throw down
not in time when that was oh they call
him out yeah it came off the bag ollie
varys is out at second base to end the
inning
mike matheny is going to check with the
replay crew and see if they want to
challenge it he says no thank you so the
inning is over
roberto perez guns down another would be
base stealer
naked is seven out of 18 with a runner
and scoring position on the year trying
to get the indians that early lead
ground ball off the glove of merrifield
reyes is going to go for third oh boy
and he's going to make it safely and the
indians take a one-nothing lead as
santana came home on the play
and tyler naquin has his 18th run batted
in on the year one nothing cleveland
it's such a big play to get yourself to
third base with nobody out
and it went up the uh the heel of the
glove of merrifield and he's going to
challenge him because he knows
murrayfield has to track it down that
ball's going away from him so he's going
to stay aggressive
josh naylor
jam shot
reyes will score they'll get the force
at second for the first out of the
inning
naylor safe at first his sixth rbi on
the year and it's two to nothing
cleveland carlos santana has scored one
of the two runs
sliced to left and alex makes a diving
play routine play for alex gordon
ball's coming in he's simply the best he
reads him well they have top spin on him
takes perfect angles knows how to catch
it knows how to stay healthy
through the catches doesn't you know it
hasn't hurt his shoulder one time that
i've seen first and third again
and another opportunity to get a run in
here after you've already put two on the
board now tyler naquin
[Applause]
over near the line will make the catch
tagging is lindor
he will come home and score and it's
three to nothing cleveland so good
fundamental baseball there rbi number 18
for nayquin baker stayed on it nothing
that gordon could do he's too deep
[Music]
so the indians are able to add one on
there that's first and third you love it
and now monday
he is over two he reached on a fielder's
choice
and monday hits it a mile
into right field and that is gone up
into the concourse how about that for a
first home run of the year a no
doubter but here you go set up again
first and third and oscar mercado coming
to the plate he's over two
ground ball it's all snared by michael
franco but he can't make a play a run
will score everybody's safe they get the
run right back
oh he made a heck of a play to snare
that ball to keep it from going into
left field
but could not come up with it cleanly
freeman has five hits and 21 at bats on
the year
mike duffini probably has the feeling
that this game is hanging in the balance
right here any hopes the royals have
rests with brad keller
right field on the move while avarice
makes the catch tagging and coming home
is perez and there are two down but
that's a heck of an at-bat by mike
freeman who hasn't had it at bats since
august 28th down on the count 1-2 i'll
lead it 5-1 zach
went seven innings and gave up exactly
one hit in every inning that he pitched
but only one run runner dozier was over
three against police hack
hit well to center field mercado goes
back and it is off the top of the wall
and now it cares toward left field so
naylor has to come over to get it
and hunter dozier has a triple and just
missed a homer you could tell he spanked
this that's 76 in the middle and he
barreled it it's right below the yellow
line
stand up triple for doji
base hit center field michael franco has
three hits he drives in dozier and it's
5-2
brad hand on the pitch for the tribe
trying to nail down
his
third save in as many days
struck him out looking boy
and five pitches five strikes
and only virus strikes out two down
took a calm third that's going to end
the ball game brad hand strikes out the
side in the ninth and the indians win
this one 5-2